[MUSIC]
RODNEY PRIESTLEY:
The students are
learning theory behind material
science characterization
techniques as well as gaining
hands-on practical experience
on how to utilize
these techniques.
This year we've decided
to break the course out
into three modules.
The second module is
based on hard materials,
characterization, and
giving students experience
on utilizing the techniques
that exist in the new Andlinger
Center for Energy
and Environment
and the Imaging and
Analysis Center.
And so there, the students are
getting hands-on experience
with techniques and equipment
such as transmission electron
microscopy or scanning
electron microscopy.
GRACE KRESGE: In lab,
we did an experiment
where we took a scanning
electron microscopy images
of a butterfly wing.
I'd like to go to
graduate school
for chemical engineering
focused on materials science,
and this course is really
going to prepare me.
It already is preparing me for
graduate-level characterization
work.
This is things that I've
seen my graduate students
in the past do.
I know that this is
getting me on track
to be a competitive candidate
to go to graduate school.